What expression can be used to
show dividing 18 boxes into
two equals stacks?
Find the expression three times
using different ways to
write division.
Find the value of
the expression.
So let's just do this
top part right here.
We have 18 boxes, and we want to
divide them into two equals
stacks, so we want to
divide 18 by 2.
And the way we would write this,
and we'll think a little
bit more about what this
means, we could write
this as 18 over 2.
This means 18 divided by 2.
We could write it as 18 divided
by 2, just like that,
or we could write it
as 18 divided by 2.
Now before we evaluate it, they
say find the value of the
expression.
Let's think about
what this means.
We have 18 boxes and we
want to divide them
into two equal stacks.
Let me draw 18 boxes.
So I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, 11, 12-- almost
there-- 13, 14, 15,
16, 17, 18.
So those are my 18 boxes, and I
divide them into two equals
stacks or two equal groups.
So if I want to divide these
into two different groups that
have the same number of boxes,
I could just eyeball it, and
say, well, let's make these
top ones one group.
Let's make that one of the
groups, and let's making these
bottom ones another group.
And these are equal groups.
How many do we have
in each group?
Well, in the top one, we have
one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, and in
the bottom one we have one,
two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine.
So we've split it into
two groups of nine.
So 18 divided into two equal
groups is equal to 9, or 18
divided by 2 is equal to 9, or
2 goes into 18 nine times.